halper desk do you prefer media
attention from offline channels such as
newspapers and magazines or from online
such as blogs and relevant sites to your
industry sure so my personal preference
just from me doing public relations for
the past 10 years or so is for the more
traditional so those online newspapers
and magazines and things like that but
for me that's just a personal preference
because I've grown up in this and like
back in the day for us to see something
in print that was like a big deal like
oh they actually thought it was that
that good of a story that is actually
printed they spent the money for it and
things like that as things slowly or
actually quickly progressed two or more
media outlets moving online of course
you still want to go after those as well
my allegiance is still too kind of those
traditional media outlets but what I'm
getting at is that at the end of the day
it really doesn't matter though what
your personal preferences it's about
where your audience is so here at Aweber
whether you're you know starting a new
company or or an established company
wherever your target audience is that's
where you're going to go I don't care if
it's a blog I don't care if it's podcast
I don't care if it's the more
traditional media you figure out where
your target audience is what programs
they listen to what things they watch
and you go there that's what you go
after I love it I couldn't agree more um
I love it I think to add to it what I
would say I you nailed it that was my
answer do you think no first it's always
harder going second know a lot is great
like absolutely you got to know where
your audiences and target just like
people figuring out hey what's social
media platform should I go on you know
where is your audience that's where you
want to be the thing that i would add
maybe to traditional versus
non-traditional is i think it can also
depend on what your goal is if your goal
is just to get a recognition and to get
credibility i think the old school stuff
still has a little more weight to be
able to say you're in the New York Times
The Wall Street Journal adds a lot more
credibility for most people than to say
you are featured on PewDiePie is youtube
channel kind of thing okay um especially
if you're dealing with a business world
that you're selling to but if you want
impact I would probably say it's easier
to get the reach by going online because
it's easier to get to a big youtuber
than it is to get to the editor of a big
traditional magazine or newspaper so I
would also in addition to ang is point
about understanding what your target
audiences I would try to think about
what's the goal is the goal just to get
kind of recognition credibility is it a
credibility statement for you or are you
trying to just drive more people to your
website and get impact because I think
that goal might impact which way you go
yeah but do both hey you know I embrace
it genius at the end don't do one or the
other you could do both yeah actually
that was something that I was hoping
would come out in the conversation as
well like media relations and media
coverage media outreach is just one
piece of the puzzle all these things
have to work together and you have to be
strategic about it but it's not going to
be one single thing that blows you up or
you know that it gets umass attention
all these things have to work together
well yeah